[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning an
explosive cbs news investigation
looks into alleged gangs of deputies
inside the los
angeles county sheriff's department our
investigation found these deputies are
allegedly encouraged to shoot people
as part of their initiation the
california attorney general launched a
civil rights investigation into these
claims last month
maria elena salinas spoke exclusively
with several deputies
who claims these gangs have existed for
decades
maria elena good morning to you this is
very very troubling stuff
good morning gail yes it is you know
usually when we think of gangs we think
of
street gangs like ms-13 or the crips or
the bloods
cbs news spoke exclusively with current
deputies out of the east los angeles
station
who claimed that the la sheriff's
department has
a huge problem
it's an open secret that deputy gangs
have existed within the los angeles
sheriff's department for decades they
operate as a gang
they commit crimes they assault people
currently the most prevalent are the
banditos
comprised of mostly latino deputies who
serve predominantly african-american
and latino neighborhoods these deputies
do not want to be identified for fear of
reprisal
cbs news has agreed to blur their faces
and substitute their voices
it's based out of east l.a but you know
members that have become banditos in
east l.a have been promoted and they've
spread all over the county
how do they identify themselves with the
tattoo
is there an initiation process to join
the gang you could say that
they could go from you getting a
shooting or you know
they do anything for these guys you said
they get shootings
what do you mean by that if you get in a
shooting that's a definite brownie point
and according to these deputies to
justify those shootings they plant
weapons on suspects
there's been multiple occasions where
they say hey we got a guy that has a gun
and he's running from us in reality that
person never had a gun
and they would say oh it was a phantom
gun it was something that really wasn't
there
so you have personally witnessed that
yes
a lot of these officers are latinos so
why are they targeting
other latinos is it racial profiling
self-loathing
they do racial profile it's like latino
gangs
they target other young latinos which is
what lisa vargas has contended all along
her 21 year old son anthony vargas who
aspired to be a chef
was shot 13 times by sheriff's deputies
while on his way home
you know we have videos with his voice
and his giggle and we have to play that
you know because we don't have his voice
no more we don't have
his smile lisa vargas filed a lawsuit
against the county of los
angeles and the deputies who shot her
son the suit
alleges that individuals who shot
anthony were members of the banditos
gang or prospects
and that membership in the banditos gang
included using excessive force
in shooting those who are unarmed they
have initiations
and in order for them to become a
prospect
their thing is they have to kill
somebody
anthony vargas was shot by sheriff
deputy nicolas perez and sheriff deputy
jonathan rojas are they also part of the
banditos gang or prospects for the
banditos
prospects yes they're prospects how do
you know
you know just personal conversations
with them and them saying that was one
of their main goals to be a part of this
gang
if you refuse to comply with their
demands to join the gang what happens
they stop giving you backup which is
very dangerous
they ignore you i have seen no evidence
of three or more deputies
engaging in a criminal activity with a
unifying symbol
whose primary purpose is to commit crime
l.a county sheriff alex villanueva has
publicly denied the existence of gangs
within his department on a video posted
to the lasd website
he warns the department's employees
against joining such groups
any employee who aligns with a click or
sub group which engages in any form of
misconduct
will be held accountable i do not want
you joining these alleged clicks anymore
period the banditos believe they can get
away with anything
and you know they're not going to have
any type of consequences for their
actions
no one is above the law newly elected
l.a county district attorney george
gascon
says he is committed to upholding the
law we take this allegation seriously
and if in fact we believe that
there is a you know criminal activity
within the sheriff's department and then
we'll deal accordingly
we need to remember it's not just the
mothers he said what does
justice look like for you and for your
entire family
justice for me is a whole long list
because not only is it
these officers being held accountable
for homicide for a murder
it's everybody else involved i want the
whole system
cleaned out
a federal grand jury investigation has
been convened sheriff villanueva
declined to comment
an investigation by the former district
attorney's office
claims that the deputies and i quote
here acted in lawful self-defense and
defense of
others when they used deadly force
against anthony vargas
deputies rojas simperes denied being
members of the prospects or
banditos anthony maria elena why did
sheriff's deputies allegedly target
anthony vargas
well anthony vargas was coming home from
a prayer group and a party
in his housing project when he was
approached by the deputies
now there was a robbery nearby however
the victim of the robbery had described
the
suspects as three male hispanics between
35 and 40 years
old anthony vargas was only 21 years old
and the victim later when he was shown
an array of photos did not identify
anthony vargas
also there was no dna or fingerprints on
the weapon that
the deputies allege that anthony vargas
had on him
and his case is only one or his murder
is only
one of several young latinos who have
died in the hands
of alleged deputy gang members
such a disturbing report maria elena
thank you so much
i know anthony it's so troubling you
have you have deputies in the department
saying this exists
you have the sheriff saying no it
doesn't exist it sounds to me like they
need an outside investigation or
something you have mrs vargas talking
about the loss of her son
who doesn't appear to have been in a
gang it's very very troubling very
troubling
come